تشهد المجتمعات في جميع أنحاء البلاد
أحداثًا متكررة من الأمطار في كل ألف عام سقطت ستة أشهر من
الأمطار في فورت لودرديل في يوم واحد فقط ،
إنه أمر محزن للغاية ، أعني أنه
يمكنك أن ترى كيف اهتزت أنا دالاس
إيسترن كنتاكي سانت لويس
ويلوستون.
أحداث هطول الأمطار في عام 2022. يا إلهي ،
لا يمكنني العودة إلى المنزل ، فما هو
حدث مطر واحد في ألف عام بالضبط ، إنه ليس
شيئًا يمكن أن يحدث فقط كل
ألف عام ، إنها طريقة إحصائية
للتعبير عن احتمالية حدوث
حدث طقس شديد  يحدث في أي
سنة معينة ، لذا فإن حدث 1000 عام لديه فرصة واحدة في
ألف أو 0.1 في المائة
لحدوثه في أي عام ، حيث
تزيد أحداث هطول الأمطار الشديدة بالفعل ، نعم ،
في حالات هطول الأمطار الغزيرة للغاية ،
كانت نسبة واحد في المائة من جميع أحداث هطول الأمطار اليومية  لوحظ
في كل منطقة من الولايات المتحدة وفقًا
للتقييم الوطني للمناخ في
الجنوب الشرقي ، زادت هذه الأمطار الغزيرة جدًا
بنسبة 27 بالمائة بين عامي 1958 و
2012.
إلى أحدث
تقييم وطني للمناخ في الولايات المتحدة ،
أدى تغير المناخ بالفعل إلى تغيير أنماط هطول الأمطار
في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، بما في ذلك
الاحتمال
المرتفع لظواهر
هطول الأمطار الشديدة.  درجات الحرارة
حول العالم يمكننا أن نتوقع رؤية
المزيد والمزيد من هذه الأحداث التي يبلغ عددها 1000 عام